bad news for donald trump's
former personal attorney rudy giuliani
he may be facing felony charges the
website law and crime
is now reporting that fulton county
georgia district attorney fannie willis
is reportedly looking into whether her
office can prosecute rudy giuliani
over a series of false statements and
conspiracy theories that he was peddling
during a session of the georgia state
legislature late last year remember that
tour that rudy did
during which he ultimately got
coronavirus where he was doing
all sorts of events at state
legislatures
filing court complaints and all sorts of
different things
according to the daily beast with an
anonymous source
familiar with the matter willis is
researching whether georgia code 161020
could be applied to the things that rudy
said before a georgia senate panel
in december of 2020 rudy told
a republican group of legislators quote
you were the final arbiter of who the
electors should be
and whether the process is fair the
other way to look at it
is it's your responsibility if a false
and fraudulent court
is account is submitted to the united
states government
and it's clear the count you have right
now is false
and what rudy was claiming was that
there were 231
000 odd ballots together with no return
record at all that 134 000 votes were
thrown
out but quote you kept 96
000 votes where there was no return
record for them
rudy implying that there were phantom
votes
and of course all of these claims were
very quickly debunked
even by republican elected officials in
georgia
but the question is whether rudy
giuliani here
may have committed a felony by
intentionally
misleading senators as well as the
people of georgia and the united states
perpetuating the disinformation and
under the law in question
it is a crime to knowingly and willfully
falsify conceal or cover up
a material fact or to make a false
fictitious or fraudulent statement or
representation
before any department or agency of state
government now in general these laws are
used to prosecute people who are
interviewed during investigations
and they say things that are untrue
knowingly untrue
and it makes it similar to you're not
allowed to lie
to federal agents and there are other
trump associates at the federal level
who have been wrapped up
because of that it's not typically used
in this exact
way but what rudy giuliani did in the
aftermath of the 2020 election as well
as sydney powell and jenna ellis and
others
is also not typical so there's no
question that this would be
it would be significant if the d.a chose
to go after rudy giuliani on this
it would be a big expansion of
investigation
uh by district attorneys within a state
uh but certainly uh rudy giuliani here
could be
in a significant legal issue and listen
even if it doesn't go very far
the possibility of it going places is
likely to lead
to to require rudy giuliani to be
well represented by council and maga
making attorneys get attorneys everybody
around trump needing to hire their own
attorneys
even trump's own lawyers now if it ever
comes to it
i am completely convinced
that rudy is going to sort of adopt the
position
of sydney powell and tucker carlson
which is no reasonable person would
believe what rudy said to be true
doesn't necessarily mean rudy was lying
but it certainly suggests that as fox
news lawyers have argued when tucker
says things that don't uh correspond to
the facts
it's because it's hyperbole it's a
performance it's an entertainment
program he shouldn't be expected to be
saying things
that are factual when sidney powell said
dominion voting systems this and
uh you know electors uh that and all of
this other stuff
um that nobody should have believed that
what she was saying was factual really
because she sounded pretty serious when
she was saying it
i assume that that's the the defense
that rudy would take
and what's amazing is i've already heard
a reaction to that
from trumpists who are saying listen
sidney powell still believes that it was
stolen
and sidney powell was serious when she
said the election was stolen
this is just an election defense saying
no one really could have believed that
as a legal defense is just a legal
defense so she doesn't get in trouble
we all know the trumpists and qanon
people are saying
we all know that the election was stolen
and she was telling the truth but now
she's only saying this to get out of
legal trouble
now what's interesting is obviously the
election wasn't stolen
but it's certainly sydney powell seems
bonkers enough
that she really may believe the election
was stolen and she really may be
using this legal defense to get out of
legal trouble that's possible
but that doesn't make it true as we now
know there is no evidence whatsoever
that the 2020 election was stolen